Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Green Lantern video for the DC movies the
DC series that they're planning right now for
HBO there's been a bunch of changes because of
what's happened with all the buyouts in James
Gunn becoming the new head of DC and all these
plans that he has for Superman the Justice
League characters all the other characters
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos it is a lot of good news even though
it does seem crazy like there's been a lot of
stuff that's gone down the past couple of years
they basically killed off the arrowverse I know
there's still tons of questions about diggle Green
Lantern I'll address that later in the video and
this reminds you of all the Ryan Reynolds Green
Lantern jokes Ryan Reynolds has been making more
Green Lantern Jokes which are way more meta now
that James Gunn is now in control of DC basically
in charge of their new versions of Green Lantern
right after coming from all the Marvel movies like
I literally just did a James Gunn Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special video I'll be doing a
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer really soon too
probably next week his shift to DC is coming just
as Ryan Reynolds is getting ready to make Deadpool
3 which will also be set inside the MCU so like
just as he's coming to the MCU doing all this
Deadpool stuff I've already done a much bigger
Deadpool 3 video because there's so much stuff
happening in that he's bringing back Hugh Jackman
as Wolverine from the fox Marvel movies they're
going full Multiverse with the TVA Mobius from
the Loki series but it sounds like he is totally
down with all the new Green Lantern stuff Ryan
Reynolds even offered his own endorsement joking
that it was all part of his plan it's all falling
into place I know there are all kinds of questions
about whether or not he'll be involved with the
franchise ever again in any capacity recently
you probably saw the video that he posted he
posted this funny video of himself re-watching
his Green Lantern movie for the first time
in forever I think he said he'd never actually
watched the theatrical cut after the premiere is
welcome to all
this planet has been our home for countless
millennia it was created for us by the Guardians
if you look real closely there you can see he's
even wearing his original Green Lantern ring from
the movie that he kept that's the actual ring that
he wore during the film also funny detail about
that movie too is that because taika watiti is an
actor he appeared during that film now obviously
both of them are big in the Marvel Universe
Green Lantern yeah yeah Green Lantern what pilot
he wore a uniform I think he was a soldier give me
this I don't think so that maybe you're thinking
of um Seth Rogen Green Hornet it's this yeah
that's where you're getting completely amazing
in that but neither of us to see it's working I
don't know you did Green Lantern it was definitely
great recently you probably saw James
Gunn confirmed that they do have plans
to bring Green Lantern to the DC movies in
addition to the TV series they're working
on for HBO in Zack Snyder even showed off
the Wayne Carr version of Green Lantern
that he shot for the Justice League
Snyder cut then Warner Brothers made
him delete this is actually the video of
that with some special effects laid in
oh wow that's awesome
seems pretty cool it's too bad the studio made
him get rid of that but if we hear anything about
them adding that back into a future version of
that movie eventually we'll find out originally
what would have happened is that he would have
appeared to Batman in the post-credits scene to
warn him about Darkseid connect the Justice League
with the Green Lantern Corps and set up a whole
group of characters through them for a much bigger
introduction in the Justice League sequels I've
already done a way bigger video on Zack Snyder's
plans for the plot of Justice League 2 and Justice
League 3 because he revealed the entire plots of
those movies I'll post a link for that video down
in the description below there was another idea I
had for the Green Lantern that wasn't Ryan and so
I thought that if we had gone down this path of
Green Lantern I would have had to have Ryan as
the additional Lantern got it so it could have
been maybe he would have been there as well as
other lanterns as well as another lantern that
would have been but that's another story there
were a couple Green Lanterns in the version of the
movie that we actually saw starting with yellinger
he was the original Green Lantern of the sector of
space where Earth resides in the comics that's why
Zack Snyder made him the Green Lantern in the dark
side War flashback scene from ten thousand years
ago like we did see the dead killwog inside that
nightmare Flash Forward sequence the potential
future timelines that the mother box shows cyborg
so during the movie when they show you this dead
killwog scene like Superman is basically floating
over the remains of the Justice League in the Hall
of Justice as if he's killed all them like he's
holding Batman's cowl that was just meant to be
one of the possible Futures as referenced by the
Kryptonian ship like you hear the voice of the
ship telling them not to proceed with their course
of action because it will lead to something very
terrible because it's also extrapolating all these
potential future nightmare outcomes but originally
what the plan was is that Zack Snyder was going
to introduce the dceu version of Green Lantern
that would have then gone on to the Green Lantern
Corps movie the same way that he introduced the
Wonder Woman character in Batman v Superman then
she went on to the first Wonder Woman film and
then came back and crossed over again same thing
with Ezra Miller's version of The Flash same thing
with cyborg all the other characters when he wound
up believing the project though things went into
turnaround and they completely changed their plan
for the future of DC movies this was all years ago
but apparently they still always planned at doing
a Green Lantern Corps movie at some point and even
before the Snyder cut became a thing originally
back in 2016-2017 his plans for the first verse
of the movie were the ending scene would be of
kill walk and tomorrow Ray the Green Lanterns
that you saw in the Ryan Reynolds Green Lantern
movie to be the ones to show up their scene would
have been pretty similar to what you saw in the
Snyder cut and what he would have done with the
Jon Stewart Green Lantern in the Snyder cut
version of that like the message was always
going to be the same the scene was always going to
be the same it was just the characters themselves
rotated over time a couple different times but
the funny thing now because of all the James Gunn
news all the transitions the Warner Brothers
buy out with Discovery is that those old John
Stewart plans like the reason why he couldn't be
in the Snyder cut were from an old Administration
they've either been fired off or left the company
and now their plans for Jon Stewart are that he's
going to be the main Green Lantern of that HBO
series that we've been talking about for the past
couple of years like right now in the DC movies
James Gunn Peter safran's new plans for all the
DC movies they've completely reworked everything
the previous administration had planned for all
the different characters originally what was going
to happen with that Green Lantern HBO series was
that it would be a little bit more like House of
the Dragon an anthology series that would jump
across time I just got done doing videos for all
the house of the Dragons season one episodes I'll
be doing episodes for season two as well but
one of the big differences between that series
and the original Game of Thrones series is that
there were massive time jumps every couple of
episodes they would have basically done that
with a bunch of different Big Green Lanterns
from the comics following their characters in
an anthology style Mark Guggenheim from Arrow
and the other arrowverse shows was one of the
main showrunner he said that they wrote all the
scripts they cast the main actors for all the
different versions of Green Lantern they were
going to do they were about to start shooting the
series before all the Warner Brothers buyout with
the discovery stuff started happening and they
basically killed off the arrowverse and then
completely sold the CW Network they would have
originally started with Alan Scott Green Lantern
in the distant past then they would have done Guy
Gardner Sinestro was going to be the main villain
but they were going to start with his rise Then
Fall turn to the Yellow Lantern ring and creation
of the Sinestro core then they would have done a
version of Jon Stewart then the more recent Green
Lanterns like Simon bass and Jessica Cruz even
later in the timeline in the basic gist is that
throughout the timeline all these Green Lantern
Sinestro Rises through the ranks becoming the
greatest Green Lantern of his age then follows
the darkness deciding that wielding fear is a
more effective tool at pacifying the universe
and rises again as the Yellow Lantern becoming
a bigger threat over time until eventually he
creates the Sinestro core like his Arc in the
comics and you have the introduction of the
rest of the emotional spectrum and the rest
of the lantern chord and they introduced the
rest of the cores from the emotional Spectrum
like the War of Light kind of vibe they did just
announce a longer 10-year plan for their Justice
League movies like The Giant crossover Avengers
Infinity War Avengers end game or like Avengers
5 King Dynasty Avengers 6 Secret Wars kind of Arc
like Marvel is doing right now and it does sound
like DC has long-term plans to do their movie
version like a much bigger version of crisis on
infinite Earth and that's what they're building up
to in the next 10 years and for those of you still
wondering what happened with diggle Green Lantern
they did wind up answering that question at the
end of the recent flash season but the basic idea
is that because they were getting rid of the CW
like they were kind of offloading it selling the
network itself getting rid of the arrowverse shows
it sounds like what happened behind the scenes
is that they told the arrowverse people you're
not allowed to do diggle Green Lantern the way
you want to do it so at the end of the recent
flash season diggle's like I'm not going to wear
the Green Lantern ring that he got earlier in the
series The basic idea is that the CW isn't really
doing arrowverse stuff that much anymore the big
Focus now is on James gun Peter Safran running DC
doing their version the Marvel Disney plus series
on HBO like DC HBO series the biggest new ones
that we've seen so far are The Peacemaker series
they're already working on Peacemaker season two
and they're working on the first Batman HBO series
it's just a spin-off of Robert Pattinson's Batman
series so there'll be a ton of new DC HBO series
it'll just take them a little while to get them
out like Peacemaker season 2 will be the next one
to come out then the Batman HBO series about the
penguin the other Batman HBO series is an Arkham
series the next one after that would be the Jon
Stewart Green Lantern HBO series then we'll also
hear about other HBO series that they're working
on like James Gunn said there's a couple others
that he's working on right now too but that's just
the beginning let me know in the comments what
other kind of big budget DC HBO series do you want
to see them do in the future big reminder we're
getting the Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
really soon you can click here for my video
on that and click here for my full Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special breakdown Easter eggs